Animal Sanctuary that lux and I have
been talking about we're doing it we
found the property we're buying it
offers been accepted the property is in
Tennessee and God it's so dope man as
far as the animal sanctuary goes is it
going to be one specific animal or is it
going to be a lot of different animals
there are 43 species of farm animals
which are ideal for interaction with
people what we want is farm animals that
need rescuing I'm dying to get
registered Animal Sanctuary organization
as a full-on legitimate charity and
non-profit which is legally known as
501c3 building attractions pens the
radical Ranch is what it's called